mach mal wieder dings hier trouble main
will hier alleine und soja habt ihr in
die kommentare geschrieben und auch bei
facebook ich mir dachte hoppla mann war
alleine auf
also nicht das irgendwie mit kabel oder
so dass jetzt nie wieder dabei sind
sondern jetzt nur erstmal hier mal
wieder alleine weil ja auch wollte dass
ich alleine ein bisschen bisschen leid
dass ich alleine aufmerksamer spiele
meint ihr glaube ich und jetzt darf man
hier herunterladen
dazu komische fehler mein pc ein neuer
pc kommt in zwei wochen am 15
kommt er an und dann das letzte film
persönlich und dann kann ich endlich mit
shader und zu allem aufnehmen also dann
ist die grafik auch sehr viel besser
warte ich mal ganz kurz den chat noch
ein bisschen runter das nervt nämlich so
auf die kennen mich wieder alle die
komische neuen heiko knafla ich heiße
blabla hd glaube ich bla bla bla bla hg
geox place auf 30 grad
und ja also meine grunde topmanager
truppen gerade erste cathedral an drei
terminen der wurzel 5 woods und frozen
cargo hat auf fünf machen wir mal
note 2 geht das einfach so apples neuer
okay okay
und zwar ist das jetzt sind updates für
problem heraus gekommen
einerseits wurde dings neuen karten
hinzugefügt wie zb eine stadtkarte dann
die karte cabin in the woods die
wahrscheinlich jetzt dran kommen wird
die ich da schon so abgestimmt ab jetzt
geht's los jahr guck dir das ist hier
neue karte links bogen und neun blödmann
und es gibt halt nur noch dieses voting
system was ich euch davor hin gezeigt
habe wo man ganz einfach wo man drei
karten zur auswahl stehen dann kann man
das machen was die user wollen und nicht
auf jedem server im gelände komische
andere band der ekd wird auch keinen
trade allerdings erstmal ein geben weil
ich aber noch keine gallen sachen da
bringt das aber relativ wenig
ich hatte aber trotzdem einen map ist
immer noch am liebsten spielt problem
also meint will wirklich so die ganz
typischen web finde ich immer noch am
besten ich brauche jetzt aber erstmal
trotzdem paar geile sachen so hier war
ich noch nie oder weil ich ja schon mal
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß nicht
jetzt tester testosteron so ich gehe
dann erst mal direkt in testreihen außer
ich bin jetzt natürlich trader das denke
ich aber nicht
jura in ostia dann gehe ich erstmal
tester ich glaube ich glaube der hamster
calle ich glaube der straight weil er
steht hier so untergeht da nicht rein
oder ich weiß nicht vielleicht geht
jetzt auch im moment ein so
wenn ich aufschreibe gesteht der
kontrast im chat dass er nicht so klug
hamster kollegin tester samstag alle
soll ihr eingehen oha da hat wohl einer
di luca auf gemacht so warte ich jetzt
einfach auf diesen server hier die
starting also das steht nun auch nicht
mehr was da so alles ist im übrigen
nicht mehr leute heavy hatte das da rein
bekommen
das ist ganz einfach und zwar müsst ihr
euch einfach die ganzen heißt sich jetzt
übrigens hampelmann
ich weiß nicht ich glaube schon
pascal tempel klopp bot island den kanal
so machen wir mal bot 3 tl 18 sekunden
ich hoffe mal
das 3 gewinnt ihr euch als hampelmann
und ich habe jetzt auch im chat haben
wenn man das auch ganz gut obwohl schon
mal sagen ihr müsst euch einfach die
ganzen server die haben wie zum beispiel
theo drei punkten cmv punkt kommt an die
assistenz clockwork dieser dass klopp
wird eine die ich glaube schon jetzt
keiner hinter mir das ist cool
nein zu viele leute als trader benutzt
übrigen bin ich fast fertig mit der
facharbeit also wenn ihr das seht bin
ich wahrscheinlich schon fertig denn
hält in nächster zeit kommen natürlich
wieder mehr bds könnt ihr euch natürlich
drückt gefasst machen so ein paar sachen
ich war mal in den ton bisschen leiser
ist mir ein bisschen zu laut und
runtergefallen und wenn dann die fahrer
aber natürlich wenn die fertig ist genau
dann kommt auch ungefähr pch nun zu
alles und dann ergänzt sich das alles
dann wird alles ganz ganz geil und blei
neue projekte werden denke ich erst mal
nicht kommen weil ich eigentlich relativ
zufrieden bin und dass ich auch an den
raten wie das mit den klicks bei euch
ist von den bewertungen her dass nämlich
alle ganz doll lieb ab nein ich habe
mich liebt habe so unmöglich ich bin ich
gestern aber es wird ich höre geschlagen
ich drücke mich weil er denkt und denken
dass er keiner drin ist im test waren du
bist im boden kleiner fritze ich will
hier raus so soll ich jetzt einfach mal
hier hin und warte hier vielleicht
drückt den knopf und wenn einer den
knopf drückt dann wissen wir auf jeden
fall dass es ein
es hakt ihn wieder server-markt der
select förmlich reckt sie mich doch ich
habe das geschrieben ist es erst da
hinter dem test da muss man schauen ja
ich schaue hinter dem tester ja jetzt
auch gut mal geht's hier das klappt
einfach so schlagen
heinig rain im keller aber sind nicht
plattgedrückt nicht plattgedrückt sei es
alle auf nick player haye oder schon tot
auch mancher kloppen werk noch nicht
erzählt sind die wir alle etwas
eine runde machen wir noch denke ich
einfach alle server gehen wo ich
vielleicht nicht so viele kennen
ich habe sich hampel frau noch 1 minute
3 ist ein bisschen zeit server wo kann
ich ja hier gucken was ich wollten kann
halo oder ist das map lobby na ja warte
ich noch mal kurz für multiplayer ein
bisschen besser vielleicht damit ihr
auch noch sehen könnte da jetzt dass es
frau seiten welt 333 geschrieben okay
die tat fünf woods ich möchte ich klopfe
talent ich möchte konnte es nicht sagen
wenn er aufnimmt das sagen ich mich aber
nie wegen den wänden kann ja ach nee ich
möchte ich jetzt mal endlich eine neue
allerdings zeigen von craft ist geil und
schmackhaft markt seine videos aber
lasst den spielen crafter du bist der
geilste youtuber wer jemand kids von
crafter con crafter bis thailand
schmackhaft obwohl die möglich sonst hey
hey sie hassen mich mal alle voll
komisch nein 3 braun nur drei stimmen
holt 34 can only ones er hat sich im
belohnt
egal es auch vorgeführt fragte er ist
wächst das rettende auch wenn sie fragen
ja wenn ich mich nicht ändern dann
google doch einfach mensch vor kraft
lassen schreibt einfach meinen namen
chet es so heißt agent krippe einfach
einschreiben
so freunde jetzt haben wir noch eine
zweite runde hinten dran da seht ihr
jetzt übrigens wieder diese aufnahme ich
nehme nicht immer trade up esse ich habe
zwar 200 oder so um den dreh 780 stand
gerade ich hatte damals mal 200 aber
keine ahnung in wie werden die ja immer
am ende des monats auf gefühlte kraft
nicht jedenfalls ist es relativ
ungünstig wenn man als youtube immer
sachen nimmt bz wenn ihr einfach wenn
ihr mich seht und ich hab mir nicht um
dann wenn ihr einfach nicht drauf geht
es relativ gut weil immer wenn ich mich
nicht umbenennen bin ich meistens
innocent also wir keinen trailer auf
jeden fall bei random killen ist
allgemein so eine sache der gesamte die
profilieren davon relativ einem relativ
großen zusammenhang und keine ahnung wie
die immer noch mit winkeln so als ob ich
erst mal 16 zeilen mache ich das nicht
mehr so ich geh jetzt da oben versuchen
eisen schwert mit zu ergattern geht an
die leiter runter erwartet ein bisschen
leute draußen ist es sondern pro tipp
schade
wenn erst die runterkommt bitte kommen
hier unter bitte komm runter bitte
kommen wir und aber bitte komm runter
das ist ein trader darunter kommt aus
einer in der anderen mann effekt bleibe
stehen
der hak werbe okay ich hab s
ich habe einen schwerpunkt
nein nein nein das ist scheiße daran die
texte mensch gerade in duisburg noch ne
runde dran zu hängen ist server weiter
in die immer wenn ich dann einmal drin
da habe ich sofort weiter zu spielen
aber ich bin ein von den servern hunde
genau dich will ich ich will dich
persönlich
schneewittchen chor sofort alles
contractor contractor contra konny
reimann pony pony popkomm kraftcom kraft
kraft hat hier ja toll so warte jetzt
versuche ich euch alter klopp wird
island hat bitte in dieser job wird ein
21 woods nicht mit rechten dingen
zugehen die wie gehen können dass sein
ich möchte dass die trader cathedral
blog wird das ist ein kapitel alter
sowas bis mich auch der bande
was soll das was soll das was wollt ihr
alle
altabt nummer so freundlich habe schon
ein video gemacht wenn ich offen im
server gehe lasst mich in ruhe damit tut
dir den größten gefallen und fragt doch
nicht ob ich aufnehme dass es eh
meistens wirklich immer der fall wenn
ich auf dem server bin aber fragt nicht
die ganze zeit und verfolgt mich nicht
und stellt euch nicht vor mich und macht
so komische bewegung damit dem video zu
sehen sein oft frage mich wie hatte es
mäßig man sein kann so und denke die
leute würden mehr von dem ganzen mist
aufnehmen denke ich werde noch ganz
viele probleme laufen wenn die ganze
zeit vor mir steht und mich die ganze
zeit rennen gilt deswegen kann ich das
auch von ganzen anderen youtube an
verstehen dass die dann nicht mehr
chaplin meindl aufnehmen
kontrakte schneewittchen kann dann werde
ich mich jetzt auf jeden fall mal
umbenennen weihnachten
gary player 96 mir jetzt ein bisschen
umdrehen höhere kader sieht mich kann er
sich nicht ich denke immer dass es am
besten ist wenn man mit pfeilen der
rechtsweg drauf macht
ich finde es übrigens gay dass die
sachen bei mir explodiert das mal so der
wie oft so kommt einer mit runter und
später kommt mit wow so weit gehen aber
conny geiler name da schreibt gary
letztens habe ich mit schneewittchen
test wäre schön für schneewittchen ist
gar nicht hier weil die schnauze halten
ja ich hab die punkte bekommen ihr
lutscher
alter ihr wisst gar nicht wie ich diese
ganzen pfeil und bogen typen hassen sie
können das auch noch versteht man ein
blödmann egal ich würde sagen das war es
jetzt mal für diese aufnahmen sind wir
jetzt mal wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr eine
positive bewertung da lassen